- So, we tried these before.
- Delicious.
- But we didn't really
know you were supposed
to put stuff in them.
- There's nothing inside.
- This time we're going
to put stuff in them.
We're probably still gonna mess it up.
- There's just nothing that looks like any
of these things in America.
- This is like a little
boat for your food.
- These are so cute.
- You put some of this stuff in it.
- Moon beams.
- [Girl in Jean Jacket] You
got a little bit of this.
- Tamarind sauce.
- [Girl in Jean Jacket] The final part is
like a big old dip.
- Your flavored water.
- Let's get to business.
- (pani puri crunching)
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
- I do get the feeling
you're supposed to take it
all in one bite.
It's like crazy (beep) good.
- The sauces are magical.
- Spicy, sweet, earthy.
- Oh, no. I'm sorry, little pillow.
- It's like a savory Gusher.
- It's like filling up
a pita with something.
- If this is the way pani
puri is supposed to be eaten,
is that how you say it?
(laughs) Probably saying it incorrectly.
Pani puri, really?
- [Man behind Camera] I don't know.
- Oh, God.
- I can't really think of an
American equivalent for this.
- And that's a problem, America.
We need to step our (beep) game up.